>> So, congratulations, you made it through the end of the Naive Bayes
learning algorithm.
That is quite amazing.
>> That's one algorithm down, two to go.
What we'll do is we'll start a list now of all the things that maybe you
should be thinking about when picking a supervised classification algorithm.
So that you have some basis for starting to make a choice between
the different algorithms that we'll be talking about.
So there are a few things that Naive Bayes does really elegantly.
>> It's actually really easy to implement.
These were with great, big feature spaces. There is between 20,000 and
200,000 words in the English language.
And it, it's really simple to run, it's really efficient.
>> There are a few things that Naive Bayes doesn't do as well that you also want
to be careful of.
>> Yeah, so it can break.
It breaks in funny ways.
So, historically when Google first sent it out, when people searched for
Chicago Bulls, which is a sports team comprised of two words, Chicago Bulls.
Would show many images of bulls, animals, and of cities, like Chicago.
But Chicago Bulls is something succinctly different.
So phrases that encompass multiple words and
have distinctive meanings don't work really well in Naïve Bayes.
>> So depending on exactly what the problem is that you're trying to solve and
the data set that you have to solve it,
you shouldn't think of supervised classification algorithms as black boxes.
You should be thinking about them in terms of the theoretical understanding of
how the algorithm works and whether that's right for
the question you're trying to answer.
>> And you should, of course, test it, right?
So we talked about train set and test set.
You can check the performance in test set and see how it works.
>> And if you don't like it might be the wrong algorithm or
the wrong parameters.
>> Exactly